[Musique]
dernière réunion du personnel avant
l'arrivée des clients dans ce restaurant
de langue island en retrait hugues
dufourt un natif d'alma supervise le
tout
[Musique]
celui qui était partenaire de martin
picard au restaurant montréalais au pied
de cochon habite new york depuis
maintenant une dizaine d'années lorsque
l'album du pied de cochon est sorti on a
été évité à orlando en floride pour
faire un événement faire des cures de
foie gras puis promouvoir le livre et
puis on était jumelée avec mon épouse
sarah aussi vu à distance pendant un bon
bout de temps
puis bon on voulait être ensemble on
voulait faire quelque chose les deux
s'établissent donc à new york et veulent
ouvrir un magasin général
donc c'est ici que tout a commencé là il
ouvre donc un restaurant pour les
voyageurs de passage
steiner est là qui est couvert de
graffitis la fois
le new york times place alors
l'établissement sur sa liste de dix
endroits incontournables à visiter dans
le monde
on avait une fille c'était de la science
fiction la fille partait du sine
puis à se rendait à se rendre jusqu'à la
moitié du pont n'avais jamais vu une
chose semblable ça se passait sua ziff
ses 400 personnes quand tu es tout seul
aux grilles d'entrée a été de très
courte durée on avait signé un bail d'un
an à l'époque on ne fait jamais nuit j'y
repense souvent devant le succès le
propriétaire décide en effet d'augmenter
le montant du loyer de 2000 $ par mois à
39 8 dollars par mois
luc dufour ferme donc le resto et
devient très courtisé j'ai eu toutes
sortes de demandes de partout parce que
j'étais peut-être un des objets de
gentrification de ce quartier là
il n'y avait aucune raison de venir à
l'ong en séries mais aucune raison dans
un langage landes désormais embourgeoisé
il jette son dévolu en 2010 sur un vieux
garage de carrosserie pour le
transformer en steak house est - elle
ouvre finalement ses portes en 2013
il ya eu beaucoup de créativité et
beaucoup de choses qu'on a fait nous
mêmes en fait j'ai tout fait moi même la
soudure que j'ai tout fait on a un
bassin truites vivantes qui est dans la
cuisine j'ai fait avec mon père mon
frère luc dufour réussira un an plus
tard à décrocher une étoile au guide
michelin
dans une ville où les clients sont
plutôt généreux avec les serveurs hugues
dufour a décidé contre toute attente
d'abolir les pourboires plonge les
hôtesses sommet lier tous ces gens là
ont pas le droit aux pourboires
techniquement dans une place où les gens
de se prénommer manche commence avec un
tiers de ton staff qui fait 20% et 25%
et puis tu as des gens qui crèvent de
faim selon lui de montréal à new york il
y à un monde de différence dans la
restauration
y'a jamais vers valises il ya les règles
à l'oral son canal 6 a aucun rapport de
toujours un danger disparaître et puis
bon on continue toujours
ça me rappelle qu'à enregistrer les
vaches ne sont pas on saute pas une
traite ici bas c'est que c'est la même
chose ouvert 7 jours semaine il ya
toujours des gens qui ont mangé longue
highland serait-elle la destination
finale de l'almatois rue du four j'ai un
bail de dix ans ici il m'a ans 4 on va
voir si on peut renouveler on
renouvellera si on peut pas en fera
d'autres choses j'y pense quand même
deux peut-être de retourner au québec
avec le recul c'était un bon coup de dés
finalement de partir et de venir
s'installer à new york
oui absolument je regrette rien de ce
que j'ai pu faire et puis je serai
heureux
la vente sur new yorkaise ici frédéric
arnould radio-canada new york